[Music]
so mark you have a great question about
black holes is there a minimum mass
needed for a black hole to form and as a
black hole form whenever a stellar
object gets that dense to begin with
let's talk about the definition of a
black hole now most commonly people talk
about black holes as being a consequence
of a giant star dying and the idea is
that a star has this huge mass and
that's a lot of gravity crushing the
star together now when the star is alive
and there are fusion reactions going on
inside the core that crush of gravity is
actually held up but once the star dies
and the fusion reactions go away the
gravity crushes inward and there's
nothing to support it anymore
so basically gravity becomes so strong
in that object that not even light can
escape and therefore we call it a black
hole that's probably the most classic
way to make a black hole is you actually
make it from the core of a dead star
that's collapsing but you might be
surprised to learn that we actually
think there are other ways to make a
black hole and the real answer to your
question is that there is no minimum
mass needed for a black hole you just
need to have the right density for an
object's gravity to be so intense that
light can't escape the universe is very
good at making black holes that are
about the size of stars it's an easy way
to get them but the universe makes black
holes in other ways too we actually
think there are black holes being
generated all around us on very very
small scales there are things called
high-energy cosmic rays very very
energetic particles that slam into our
atmosphere from space
these slamming with enough energy that
we think they actually create tiny black
holes black holes that have the mass of
only a couple atoms there's enough
energy to cram that matter together so
much they form little black holes one of
the things that we're doing in CERN
which is actually the largest particle
accelerator on the earth right now is
trying to get up to those densities CERN
actually does want to make artificial
black holes actually have two particles
collide so intensely that they pop off a
little black hole and before you ask the
question no this is not dangerous
CERN does not get up to energies
anywhere near what's happening in the
natural world these high-energy
particles from space are much more
energetic than CERN can ever do so if
anything dangerous was gonna happen it
would already have happened these tiny
little black holes we think don't live
very long maybe even a millionth of a
second the whole point will be to detect
them at all all you need is a certain
amount of mass in a certain amount of
volume it doesn't matter how much mass
and you'll get a black hole for example
if you could actually crush the entire
earth into the size of a ping-pong ball
that would be a black hole but now let
me tell you that things go the other way
too we know a black holes that are much
much more massive than stars there are
things called supermassive black holes
that are millions or billions of times
the mass of the Sun we see these in the
center of galaxies all around us and
quite honestly one of the biggest
questions in astronomy right now is how
do these giant black holes form because
we see them so far away in space we see
them in galaxies that are ten billion
light-years away and that means that 10
billion years ago when the universe
wasn't very old you already had black
holes that were billions of times the
mass of the Sun now those supermassive
black holes are really interesting
because remember I told you the whole
point is getting the right density for a
black hole doesn't really matter how
much matter there is intriguingly these
giant black holes are actually not very
dense on average if you had a black hole
that was about four million times the
mass of the Sun the diameter of that
black hole would be about the orbit of
where Jupiter is in our solar system and
the average density of it across that
whole volume would be about the same as
water so how is it you could have a
black hole that only has the average
density of water aren't black holes
extremely dense things well this all
depends on the amount of mass that you
have so if the earth were a black hole
you'd have to take all of the earth and
crush it to the size of a ping-pong ball
think about how dense that would be that
would actually be on the order of a
sextillion tons within a cubic
centimeter really really dense for these
really massive black holes you have a
lot more mass and that means you don't
actually need the
density to bend space quite as much one
of the ways I can explain this is to use
an analogy saying that you have a rubber
sheet and in order to get a black hole
you have to make the bending of the
rubber really really extreme you have to
drop something under the rubber sheet
that will bend it down so maybe you have
something that's just the size of a
marble and in order to get a really good
strong bend in that sheet it has to be
the density of lead really dense now say
you have something big like an elephant
you put the elephant on the rubber sheet
you get a lot of bending even though the
elephant is on average a lot less dense
than lead so if you have more matter it
will create a bending of space even if
it's not very dense and amazingly that
does mean that the biggest black holes
in the universe have the average density
of a beer
[Music]
you